we asked Americans about their
favorability towards private and public
institutions first we found that
Americans tend to prefer private sector
firms to public sector firms Americans
also tend to prefer institutions that
let them choose between the firm's that
they use and what I mean by that is that
people can switch grocery stores people
can switch the bank that they go to it
gets harder to switch your local
government or your state government and
it becomes even harder to switch your
federal government and this probably
explains why eighty eight percent of
Americans have a favorable impression of
their local grocery store whereas only
thirty-three percent have a favorable
impression of the federal government so
with the 2012 presidential election
approaching we have several GOP
presidential candidates talking about
abolishing and consolidating that the
federal bureaucracy Americans are fairly
evenly divided about whether they would
like to abolish and consolidate the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development or keep it as it is with
forty four percent in favor of Allah
Shing and forty-seven percent oppose and
this is especially interesting because
despite its existence we've still had a
housing boom and bust in general a
majority of Americans aren't quite ready
to say they want to abolish these
federal departments what we did find
though is that between thirty to forty
five percent of Americans do favor
abolishing and consolidating these
departments so it's hard to argue that
wanting to abolish I'm in consolidate
these federal departments is fringe or
way outside the mainstream reeling from
the onset of the 2008 financial crisis
politicians and political candidates
seem to rally around a similar mantra in
which they said we might not agree about
what we should do but we can agree that
government needs to do something so in
2011 we asked Americans what were they
more concerned about were they more
concerned about government failing to
take action or were they more
that government would take action but
that action would make things worse and
we found that a majority of Americans
fifty two percent actually are most
concerned that the government will take
action but that action will make things
worse we also surveyed Americans
willingness to consider specific
third-party candidates who might enter
the 2012 general election of twenty one
percent of americans said that they
would or might consider voting for
former new mexico governor gary johnson
we also asked about congressman ron paul
thirty-five percent of americans said
they would or might consider voting for
him in the general election and
thirty-three percent said they would
consider voting for new york mayor
michael bloomberg
you